لطالما شكلت تعداد السكاني بعد 2003 مشكله
جدليه بين الفرقاء السياسيين تظهر في
مواسم الانتخابات النيابيه والمحليه
تحفظ كردي سني طيله الفتره الماضيه خشيه
الاقصاء والتهميش من قبل البيت السياسي
الشيعي انذاك عشرون عاما كانت كفيله على
ما يبدو بتبديد تلك المخاوف ابدا هكذا
سؤال غير موجود لا في التعدادات السابقه
التي شهدها العراق شهد العراق على خلال
تاريخه الماضي ثمانيه تعدادات وهذا هو
التعداد التاسع الذي يعني نعمل على اجراءه
لم يكن سؤال عن المذهب بالمطلق كان سؤال
في يعني في التعدادات سابقه عن الدين وانا
القوميه الان في التعداد المقبل سيكون
سؤالا واحدا فقط عن الدين
الجانب السياسي المعلن ليس كل شيء فثمت
جوانب اخرى فنيه تقع على عتيق وزاره
التخطيط الجهه المعنيه الاولى بهذا
التعداد الذي تم تنفيذه اخر مره عام
1997 فنيا اقول نعم الوزاره يعني ولها
تجارب مهمه في هذا المجال نحن سبق وان
نفذنا يعني خلال مرحله السنتين الماضيتين
نفدنا حوالي سبعه او ثمانيه عمليات
سميناها
تجريب يعني
تجارب قبليه نسميها في محافظات بغداد
نفذنا تجربتين في البصره تجربه في الانبار
تجربه في كربلاء تجربه في اربيل تجربه في
في دهوك باقليم كردستان تجربه
26 عاما من دون احصاء او تعداد سكاني كانت
كفيله بضياع بوصله الاقتصاد وتوقف عجله
التنميه والسبب قله البيانات والصوره
الضبابيه حول عدد السكان واحتياجاتهم
الاحصاء السكاني يعتبر خطوه اساسيه يعتمد
عليها المخطط
لتغطيه كل احتياجات البلد والبواطن وعقبات
كثيره امام
التخطيط امام التعداد السكاني يعني الوصول
للمكانات النائيه وللمواطن
الاحزاب السياسيه تخاف لا تقل مكاناتها
عدم وجود ارقام حقيقيه للنسب السكانيه جعل
ابناء محافظات الجنوب على وجه الخصوص
يشعرون بالمظلوميه والتوزيع غير العادل
للثروات حيث تطفو اراضيهم على ابر النفط
بينما يعيش اكثر من نصفهم تحت خط الفقراء
تخصيص الام
وال ريان بالضروره اجراء هذا التعداد خاصه
وان جهات سياسيه دائما ما ضغطت باتجاه عدم
اجرائه طيله المده الماضيه لانه سيفضح
دعائه طالما كانت حجه تستند اليها تلك
الجهات سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات